in other media scopes like how how you
quad encase it just things of that
nature
[Music]
it's creating its snapchat we're dealing
with snapchat we have to find the
restriction that creates the upside the
disappearing content was a restriction
like that the only people that can
compete with Facebook and right now is
restrictions like the all the
opportunity of social media is around
restrictions now one post a day I want
to launch a social network only for the
first year out of college literally it's
called 23 you're only allowed to be
there when you're 23 years old like
that's who's going to win like the 50
yeah 100% restrictions like in a world
where a month ago all sorts of different
scopes looks up in the air you know
bedrooms become choosers really quickly
when they've been fed remember I feel
like you filming make head feel like you
missed that bro see me I'm well can we
life is good give me two seconds you
know it's just a phase I'm agnostic
right I want what's best for everything
so you should really take me up on that
if something is going great if something
is not going great
if you're curious about something I've
got answers like I want to fix things
I'm not scared of it there's no like I
feel like I'm a kid
there's no Emperor's not wearing clothes
I know I'm a kid yeah I'm running a
company cool awesome it have a great
yeah yeah yeah really nice and hopefully
more to come
[Music]
hey brother over empathetic reaction to
my disappointment oh yeah great story
what that is a great story over
empathetic yeah my this point that's how
we rolled off cool we've got a real cool
thing in a minute I'm going to bathroom
I can get you in there in my office on
this episode
storytelling superstar Morgan Spurlock
stops by I'm super fired up for this
phenomenal guess it's ironic is really
first time we're jamming yeah we've
interacted a little bit on Twitter yeah
then we ran into each other I think on a
plane I was like hey you should come no
the best part is like then you walk by
and then i DM you I was like hey you
should be a guest let me ask a TV show
you're like sure and here we are two
weeks later so what do you equate your
ability to break through them what
everybody aspire to do yeah in a world
where they didn't achieve that and you
did you like honestly especially because
there's an entrepreneur format I mean a
lot of it you willed it I think you any
it's you not only will you but you don't
quit I think what any of these that's
there's a lot of people give up quit
easy easy stay in the world and and I
just I don't know I just yeah I grew up
with parents immediately ever like
whatever you start to finish
yeah you never like no matter what it
was like baseball they're like nope
you're not into the whole season you
know I would never able to quit anything
interesting I and I grew up you know
what my father who's an entrepreneur we
started a business out of our garage
that grew into a huge business and so I
mean for me it was always about I've got
a state of course I've gotta see it
through thank you my man great really
really this is a lot of fun yeah you
keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
really I'm going to be
exactly guys crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] dailyvee
and askgaryvee are on both episode 255
right now Sabri both of them are up to
55 right now so right now if you go to
youtube both them are on to 55 I want to
give away two hundred fifty five dollars
I just you and I have a relationship
it's just better even if it's a few
minutes yeah I really you know need it I
know you know but it's weird that it
should be the other way yeah good to
meet you finally
five seven eight years in the making
Mike how are you horrible
Marco pleasure how's it going don't
listen to this guy though because he's
going to trick you he's super-slick
very nice it was nice meeting you
[Music]
you've got to find the vulnerabilities
and the truth is there's a lot of that
and so it's an interesting time I mean I
think for most ejek standpoint
understanding the dynamics of the
private label business and the
infrastructure that you guys have in
your market I mean there's a really you
know you you know when I think about it
I'm a businessman before I'm a creator
when I think about what the impact on
you professionally can be if you can win
in this market at a global level the
stakes are extremely high and exciting
and that doesn't that doesn't that
doesn't come lightly from my perspective
I I recognize how big of an opportunity
this really is how are you we were going
to tell you one the circuit
Podcast okay yeah that we're going to do
today I'll do scheduling up okay so
what's happening here the suits in it
worry where do you why I'm living in DC
but we are from Ohio and I'm watching
you are special messages after our life
absolutely how are you mr. David nice to
meet you brother and you only right now
I love it how I know where that's where
it starts very nice man good luck man
thank you brother give me a lot of
motivation mile Thank You Man
you're not gonna yeah enjoy yourself
yeah sure look if you open the apples
podcast store right now my Gary B audio
experience is the number 28 biggest
podcast in the world bigger send like
tons of NPR shows correct and you are
too and I know you could be a top 100
podcast and it would speed up the FQ way
quicker than if you dominated email
social and and a website so now I also
know that were to good business people
we've got a million things going on my
intuition ironically says let me produce
a show right that you're the star of and
and it's a very lightweight he'll it
speeds up you being a top personality at
scale and then you send the economics
into your thing okay love you see ya bye
sorry
speed hello
[Music]
understood
let's do it it solved he's going to have
to say yes hey brother you have Alex
finds email good you know out great
that's right I forgot about that so
email Alex and CC me on it be like hey
don't ever send a [ __ ] email when you
will have to so what do you think just
record didn't realize it that would be
really bad it's a difficult five an 11
that's devastating setback for branches
if we didn't beat the chief and we
didn't get the Chiefs in a meaningless
game we would have Matt Ryan as our
quarterback and that's what we can't
allow to happen this time we would have
been three instead of six would've taken
Ryan and that was real [ __ ] good yeah
yes I'm aware remember I came very
clearly Chiefs for no reason I think
that we have to be smart in like at
least attacking this in reverse engineer
what we're trying to pull off here if
we're doing see what's always what what
I don't want to do is make the mistake
that I can see me walking into which is
my stuff always works because I don't
need it to be successful for 24 36
months after I started I don't know if
we're going to have that luxury
okay good awesome thanks Jerry
how are you much how's your day going
great okay waiting around for you and
good to join us tearing picking up
little things here and there talking
with your staff very cool good stuff
good thank you so much yeah yeah I don't
know if you remember the situation that
brought me here
yep okay cool um massive empathetic
reaction I think that's just amazing
great case study I mean it's not a
little old lady is like on Christmas
customs it's got that DNA yeah it does a
little bit also you know think
happen for a reason right yeah so who
knows like Walter oh you know the truth
is I'm just uh turley not transactional
like I think Karma's practical I would
never
you wouldn't do these kind of things if
you if you would then layer the stress
of making it worth your while
you know to me just do it it's the doing
the right thing is always the right
thing awesome thank you my pleasure
real pleasure man yeah real pleasure man
glad you made the trip I enjoyed it yeah
you created a question that you can
answer based on what you guys already
have read and water and then just give
you a little bit of context so that you
can sort of like talk to these younger
people and this is coming as manifesting
as a what kind of output so look if you
grew up in Beijing Shanghai you're now
in Harvard Stanford NYU a community
college I don't give a crap if you're in
the US market or other markets globally
and you're going to bring that
sensibility or IP back home and do your
thing one of the things that I highly
recommend is realizing how commoditize
the information is you Google I promise
you right now watching my thousand
videos on YouTube is going to make you
much better branding and marketing
expert than 90% of the universities in
the world who are teaching curriculum
that is outdated what I would do which
is unique advice definitely for a
Chinese market that over indexes and its
value of information education is I
would shake hands and kiss babies when
you're in America if you're at Wharton
your job is not to figure out
information that's commoditized on the
internet your job is to shake hands and
make as many relationships of the future
leaders of the global marketplace so
this could be this is very
countercultural for American elite
students this is double countercultural
for you because of what your parents
have told you to do
look I'm unpopular here in the u.s. I
might as well be unpopular in China with
parents you need to meet people it's
about the people it's literally the
relationships that you may
at these universities that are going to
over index your skill set it's not about
siphoning out the curriculum you can do
that from home in Beijing you need to
shake hands and build relationships
those are the business development
opportunities of your next 20 to 50
years bye guys thank you so much thanks
for hanging yeah take care yourself Toki
soon cycles innovation it takes a pretty
you know lofty time that people describe
a market cycles I think right off the
bat we'll just get what does the cycle
of innovation means you too early too
late you're dead you know fast follower
with understanding pattern recognition
you make all the money person slightly
behind that person not bad
you'll get a little fed person slightly
behind that not good person behind that
dead and loses lots of money yes Tom Tom
for me right on my two dollars here we
go Oh an original Thundercat in package
this goes for 100 angry quality and
great shape there's a great shape what
year is this if this is later this could
be one of the good ones this is its 87
o'clock this could be worth a lot of
money their minds are way better shape
than that don't even disrespect and wait
am i that's four so go to completed
items they're such a rookie okay let's
go down let's go down let's go down hit
right there
completed listings not sold completed
because I can do a better indication on
like sell versus not sell ratio now sort
by price 65 bucks telling you man she's
[ __ ] rare [ __ ] I'm pumped
ready 65 bucks dude this [ __ ] [ __ ] is
rare guys you're missing the boat to
wake up at 6 a.m. Saturday I really wish
I don't want to buy the jet so it's
Garagiola Tanya I gotta hang this well
I'm outta here
no evil not far from me I don't mind
shut the room got a raw form right watch
for me [ __ ] what's good for me I'm
trying a little faster I'm a shad see
them green passion I'm waiting up like
the rafters just trying to get it
fastest young trying to crack already go